[Music]
so i'm holly katrin
and i'm going to present on a sare grant
that we completed
introducing a new or a unique
application of cover crops in a garden
market operation
these are just a few um farm pictures
and
my husband jim and i had a dream to own
a farm
i grew up on the corner of a family farm
up in northern indiana
and we were for some reason all about it
and kind of compelled to own it and
sometimes i think people that farm
are like driven to do it it's like you
have to do it so that's how we felt
so um we were all about
animals and just having fun on the farm
and then healthy food
we have seven grandkids and we like to
teach them about food and farming and
kind of some of those roots
so we purchased a 11 and a half acre
farm in lebanon
indiana which is in boone county and we
named it hallelujah acres farm
and here's just a a picture of it
we wanted to our first goal was to grow
our own produce
and be able to preserve that and kind of
eat it year round
and you can see our barn there but the
first
piece of land that we tilled was just in
front of the barn
on the side it hadn't been tilled before
it was under grass and then you can see
in the distance those um there were two
pastures
there's two pastures on the farm that we
ended up tilling up one of them so
probably about a half an acre total
and then beyond that was a small um
woods
and then to the left was a six acre
hay field so we purchased our little
tractor
and began to work our soil which was the
sandy loam
type of soil at that point the state of
the soil was very clumpy
it retained water it was really hard to
plant seeds in it and then get the seeds
to grow subsequently
so we began right away to use some
winter cover crops we used a mixture of
crimson clover
daikon radish and oats
and we also added some compost to the
land
so after about two years that soil was
easy to work it was more porous
had a lot of earthworms in it and in
many cases we
didn't need to tell so in that length of
time we just saw this
significant change in our soil
so do you use cover crops now is one of
my questions and we've heard a lot about
the benefits of it but we are like true
believers in it
um healthy soil is critical to plant
growth
and a sustainable way to build the soil
is through the use of these cover crops
sown after the plants are harvested
in the fall usually late summer to early
fall
and then incorporated in the spring
but one of the questions in our minds
was can cover crops
do more so can we do more with it
so in the meantime um having grown our
own food in 2016 we became a market
garden
our goal was to provide healthy chemical
free food to
our community and in boone county there
weren't a lot of
growers at that time so the timing was
perfect for us to do this and
we were well received in the community
um we uh participated in two local
farmers markets and this picture is a
picture of the whitestown farmers market
which was
relatively new at that time
we managed 25 csas
we provided some on-farm sales and some
online sales
also through one of the food hubs
and we had fruit vegetables eggs we also
had some dairy goats
so we did some herd shares offered those
and then we had a really small mushroom
operation because we
learned about that and couldn't help but
do it so we had that
um and if you're not familiar with the
sara grants
i like to think of them as kind of an
experiment
so basically you get a grant and you're
trying to solve a problem that you have
on your farm
in this case our problem was a lot of
weed pressure um probably
probably because what we tilled up was
pasture and
um grass area so when we were thinking
about
and learned about the sare projects we
thought about three different options
and they're kind of listed here
but this controlling weeds through
interceded cover crops
but then we also thought effective
succession planting
on the soil would be a good one or
control pass-through companion planning
so we did go ahead and apply for that
first one
the sarah grant really funds research
and education projects
and they keep all that knowledge in a
database so that you can go and refer to
that when you're looking for information
we applied for the farmer rancher grant
and the program's run since 1988
and it funds projects and conducts
outreach designed to improve
agricultural systems
okay
so our project specifics our goal was to
measure the effectiveness
of inter-seeded cover crops for
proactive weed prevention
in a chemical-free low-till vegetable
market operation
and we received 7 500 was awarded to us
what we wanted to compare is the labor
and cost
to implement our prevention strategies
the weed pressure so kind of the results
of our work
the labor to remove the weeds
and then the impact of soil health of
using the
various methods
one of the tasks that we had to complete
was um
choosing what cover crops we were going
to use
for the i call it an experiment but for
the project okay
that piece was not as easy as it seemed
it would be
you have to look at the cover crops and
say do they use or produce the nutrients
that that specific plant needs
do they conserve or use soil moisture
and do they encourage or discourage
insect pests
what is the length of the growth cycle
of the cover crop
compared to the actual vegetable crop
and then when do you plant it to have
that impact on weed prevention
here are two of my favorite resources
and i noticed lori had one of these up
but
um this managing cover crops profitably
is a sare handbook
and then the cover crop field guide
we found was really helpful in doing
this but it took a little while to
analyze this which
kind of surprised me
so our final decisions um we took
several of our different crops so we
took green peppers
and decided that we would try some with
the buckwheat
as that inner seeded cover crop we would
try some with paper mulch
and some with hoeing and kind of compare
and contrast those to see what our
results are
were tomatoes we looked at crimson
clover
interceded red plastic mulch
or hoeing
summer squash we wanted to try the
icicle radishes and thought they could
also be a secondary crop
hoeing and nasturtiums
and then for the broccoli and onion we
looked at crimson clover plastic mulch
for the onion only
and then hoeing
our process um was to first submit some
soil tests
um like the pre
count the reeds weed starts so if you
look at the picture
um here we built a box
like one foot by one foot and in order
to count the weed starts we would place
the box on the ground and then count
what was within it so that gave us a way
to um
compare you know how many weeds were
there
compare the cost and time for
installation
track our labor
and then take all of our data and
compare it and then
be able to report that out and then
finally submit
soil test post because one of our
thoughts was that
because we're using these cover crops
we thought the soil might improved
improved through that use
and you can see here the tracking sheet
we used in our um
garden where we specified what crop and
row and the date
what we did the weed count at that time
and then the the time it took us
so for our results i'll just run through
those quickly but
um we decided that for hold on one
second
okay that we would use the paper mulch
for the green
peppers or be very careful um how we
planted the buckwheat
so as you can see on the picture on the
right in the center there that actually
is a green pepper
okay so we planted the buckwheat it grew
very quickly
we had kind of a coolish spring so that
green pepper plant did not grow quickly
and we ended up with um the buckwheat
overshadowing the green pepper so this
is just to me a good illustration of
um picking the proper timing and maybe
the proper
cover crop
with tomatoes we're going to use the
plastic mulch for the tomatoes
we did the inner seeding of the crimson
clover and it it just did not work out
well for us
we had a lot of weed pressure so that
may be some reason for that
but overall it just didn't for us do the
trick
for the summer squash we had a great
success using those icicle radishes
um we only usually use one
plant um planting and we would use
multiple plantings in the future
um we were able to use those as
secondary
crops and you could just plant those
several times and take them out and
that would work well and then we did not
have
any luck with the nasturtiums um for
some reason nasturtiums
never grew well in our soil so we
were going to go back to marigolds for
some of the pest prevention
we did use white clover in the aisles
and that was very successful in fixing
nitrogen so you can see the picture to
the right
the white dots are actually nitrogen
that was fixed in the soil as a result
of that
white clover so that was a good thing
and that would make that nitrogen
available to the plants
um for broccoli and onion we will use
the plastic mulch for the onions
and the crimson clover worked well for
the broccoli
here's a chart that kind of illustrates
some of our data
on the left hand side we're looking at
weed count
the yellow is the hoeing the green is
the cover crop and the
kind of the orange or red is the
plastic mulch and you can see that the
as far as weed count
the plastic mulch was most effective but
the cover crop was pretty close to it
in the center one the same thing with
time and this did include the time also
to remove the weeds so it makes sense
that it's pretty consistent with the
wheat count
and then finally on the right hand chart
the cost to install the mulch
was the plastic mulch was higher than
the cost to
plant the cover crops so that's
something to consider
in your operation
we were able to hold a couple of grant
sarah grant field days they encourage
that you share your
information you receive with your
community and we had the boone county
master gardeners in our garden
and hosted them to talk about this sarah
grant and we also worked with the
lebanon high school
ffa group and they came out to the farm
to learn about this
[Music]
you